no justice no free no justice no please
no justice no please
i love y'all they didn't choose their
part in america's racial reckoning
it chose them she started screaming on
the phone you know he
they shot him they shot him and i'm like
who the police
jacob blake was told in a phone call his
son jacob jr
was shot by police he didn't know there
had been seven bullets
until he saw it on video seeing the man
pull my son his shirt
and continuing the fire when he had his
shirt in his hand
watching him walk around the vehicle
i'm counting the seconds that he's
walking around the vehicle
when he began to shoot he kept shooting
and i said oh he's trying to kill my son
i am angry i am disgusted
because it's completely unacceptable and
anybody
who isn't angry to some degree some
effect
or discuss it by the actions that they
seen in that video
if they're not there's something wrong
[Music]
this was the weekend scene at a public
park in charlotte north carolina
in this country at this time everyday
life runs parallel to everyday protest
somewhere
[Music]
it's driven by scenes of violence played
out on social media
in the case of jacob blake three of his
sons in the car
saw their father shot with their own
eyes
you know they fear the police the little
one
screams he saw a police car and he just
started screaming
what was going on back in the back seat
and his older brother said he saw a
police car
every 24 hours it's pain it's not my
pain
jacob blake is still in hospital
paralyzed from the waist down
his family says the seven times he was
shot last month
wasn't the first time four years ago he
sustained three gunshot wounds
as the victim of an attempted robbery i
looked at his clothes they had holes in
it but i didn't see any blood
and when he turned around his butt back
was covered in blood and
he had been shot three times in recent
days the political debate here has
shifted its focus
onto the u.s supreme court the death of
justice ruth bader ginsburg
and who will replace her the politics of
all that
will play out between now and election
day the politics of all this
won't go away
[Music]
i would die if i could change places
with my son
i would lay in that bed without even a
hesitation
if i could take on the pain that he had
i would take it on without hesitation
because i love him he's my
son and i
you know i don't know how to explain
that
james matthews sky news in charlotte
north carolina
you